Ah,
the good old days before electricity.
Did we actually have it better before the first power plant started running?
What if everyone on earth tried getting by with all their lights turned off?
We'd start the challenge with a perfect earth hour,
60 minutes of complete darkness,
no artificial light allowed.
Would we reduce the light pollution enough to be able to see the milky way in
the night sky?
How much electricity would we save?
Would it help us fight climate change?
This is what f and here's what would happen if everyone in the planet switched
off the lights for an hour.
Humanity has spent the last 100 years increasing our dependence on electricity.
Look around your computer,
microwave,
fridge,
elevator traffic lights,
public transportation,
everything relies on electrical power.
Going completely without power,
even for an hour would be pretty uncomfortable.
So let's just limit humanities.
Light usage,
hit the lights and let's begin.
On average,
humanity consumes 62,000 terajoules of electricity per hour.
That's how much energy your gas powered car would need to drive to Pluto and
back twice.
One fifth of all this energy goes towards lighting.
That's a lot of energy and producing.
It means spewing a lot of carbon dioxide into the atmosphere.
Obviously clean energy from the sun.
Wind and water don't effect co two concentration in the air,
but they only make up one third of global electricity production.
The rest of it releases greenhouse gas emissions.
The thinking is if we gave our power plants and our break,
we'd significantly reduce those co two emissions on a global level.
What an easy way to fight climate change together or is it turns out it's rather
complicated.
If this worldwide earth hour cut you at night,
getting by with the light of some cozy candles is not the best idea.
Not only are they a hundred times less efficient than your light bulb,
but guess what?
They also emit co two in theory,
you could even the score by using just one candle for every light bulb he turned
off,
but if you lit up twice as many candles,
you'd actually be admitting Morrissey too.
What if you didn't light any candles?
You might think we'd admit less carbon dioxide into the air,
but you'd be wrong.
Again,
that's not how power plants were.
The coal burning ones would in fact emit less co two during the dark hour,
but then everyone would turn the lights back on for power stations.
This sudden increase in demand would mean firing up more generators.
As a result,
they would admit even more co two and this extra carbon waste would start to
trap more heat in our lower atmosphere,
possibly speeding up climate change,
and that's if power plants were able to cope with such a rapid increase in
demand.
In a worst case scenario,
they'd need to perform an emergency shutdown leaving us with no electricity for
days.
When that happened,
you would at least get to enjoy a view of the milky way at night of view.
That light pollution prevents one third of the world's population from seeing so
maybe you shouldn't pledge yourself back into darkness.
There are better ways to fight climate change than off all the lights.
At the same time.
For starters,
you could try replacing all your incandescent light bulbs with compact
fluorescent ones or take public transportation more.
What do you do to reduce your carbon footprint?